so the president last night in
washington citing the war in ukraine to
push his green energy policy the
following is a quote
from the official white house transcript
democratic fundraiser in d.c last night
so much of this was about climate change
here is uh one quote here
russia and ukraine is another reason why
we have to get off our dependency on
fossil fuels
imagine where we be right now if in fact
europe was in fact energy free of fossil
fuels and was
we were in a situation where we
it was all renewables it'd be a
different world
well it's 2022 and karl rove has some
thoughts on this carl good morning to
you if it were 2042 maybe you'd make an
argument like that you saw the
transcript from this i read it as well
what did you make of it carl
uh this is a dangerous territory for the
president be venturing in i mean people
want to hear the facts they want to be
told the truth they want to be told why
these things are happening and they have
experienced a year of inflation they
know that this that what they're paying
at the pump and what they're paying at
the grocery store is not the result of
vladimir putin it is the result of the
policies of this government and for the
president to be talking about this ju
shows why in the latest abc ipsos poll
70 percent disapprove of biden's
handling of inflation and inflation is
looming as the biggest issue
economic issue here at home in 2022 and
the biggest issue at the polls okay um
there's more polling
that well i mean it shows america is
going sideways on this
what's the obsession with climate when
china continues to burn more coal
what what's the obsession
do you think putin is raising climate
change in these summits either with
biden or trump or obama before him
no no look
look we're the only major industrialized
economy in the world that is
simultaneously growing its economy and
reducing the absolute level of
greenhouse gas emissions uh china is not
even obligated to start reducing its its
annual emissions for for a number of
years to come same with india and and i
repeat we are the only major
industrialized economy to be
simultaneously growing and reducing its
greenhouse gas emissions and we've been
doing it for decades and again this is
dangerous territory for the president
think about this
new e
economist yougov poll biden says what he
believes
36 percent
says what he thinks people want him to
hear 47 percent and 18 percent undecided
think about that nearly two-thirds of
the american people already believe
either he's just telling us what he
thinks we want to hear or i don't know
but i'm sort of leaning against him this
is a dangerous place for the president
to be and it's because when a president
loses his credibility
he begins to be seen as a weak leader
think about this also in the same
economist yougov poll very strong leader
13 percent
somewhat strong 24 somewhat weak 20
very weak 43.
now once those numbers get baked in it's
hard to
reverse them and the president has
created this problem for himself by not
shooting straight with us americans know
that that you know think about this the
last year that trump is in office
gasoline prices
dropped 30 uh i dropped three percent
they've grown 43 from january of 2020
um uh one to january of 2022
so
uh you know but we've lived through this
we're living through it in our real
lives and for the president not to be
shooting straight with us causes us to
doubt him and when we begin to doubt the
president he begins to become a weaker
leader in our eyes and a weaker leader
in reality on one more point on this he
talked about putin and coveted blaming
them you know supply chain all that
stuff for inflation that was the
rationale he used that but the reason
you keep coming back to climate as a
democratic politician because
that's where the money is isn't it
on the progressive left that that's
where you get fundraising
well and that's where you get enthusiasm
and they're looking at these same polls
and they're finding out that he's got a
problem with suburban voters he's got a
problem with independence and he's got a
problem with his own base with a lot of
people on the left after he promised to
be a transformational president once he
got into office after running as the
normal guy in in the election they got
enthusiastic about the guy that they saw
in office he raised their expectations
he's not been able to deliver and again
it causes people on his
inside his party to say weak leaders so
he got he's got problems all over the
board but rather than trying to solve
the problem with independents and
suburban swing voters first he's decided
he's going to play to the base he's been
playing to the base for a year and a
quarter and it hasn't worked why does he
think it's going to change now imagine
where we be right now if in fact europe
was free of fossil fuels today that's a
pipe dream while the war continues carl
thank you nice to see you
thank you for your time thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now